foreign
I am a developer educator at posit and a
professor of the practice at Duke
University I mainly teach statistics and
data science and today's agenda is
teaching the Tidy verse in 2023. I am
going to talk to you a little bit about
the code base that has changed in the
Tidy verse over the last year and really
when I say last year I mean the Academic
Year and there's an accompanying blog
post to this video that you are welcomed
and encouraged to read through for more
details as well but before we get
started with the Tidy verse let me start
with a little bit of a um trick for you
so this is usually what my rstudio IDE
looks like when I get started teaching
this is sort of the color scheme the
theme I prefer to use when I am working
on my own during the day this is what I
prefer when I'm working at night and
this is what I prefer when I'm teaching
and the way I've changed through these
different themes is I've written a
package that has a bunch of like a
personal package that has some add-ins
for me so I can quickly switch between
teaching mode and modes that I like
themes that I like to
um use when I am actually working on my
own I recommend getting some shortcuts
for yourself like this as well so we are
going to start by loading the Tidy verse
and the Palmer Penguins packages that
we're going to use for some of our data
examples and I'm going to load two other
packages GT and package load we're going
to use these for just a couple things
along the way the first thing I'm going
to talk about is the native pipe your
tidy verse pipelines may have looked
something like this in the pi in the
past you start with a data frame and
then you pipe that into say a deep wire
function like count and the result looks
something like this
um since R 4.0 you can now use the
native pipe here as well and you're
going to get absolutely the same answer
so you might be wondering why would I
want to do that well one of the nice
things about using the native pipe is
that it's going to work even sort of
outside of the Tidy burst or outside of
loading the mcgrid air package as well
so let's go ahead and restart our so now
none of my packages are loaded again and
let's add uh something else something
like start with the mpg create a frame
or maybe even empty cars data frame and
then let's use a base R function like
summary
um even though I have none of the Tidy
Works packages loaded or the magritter
package loaded I'm able to use the
native pipe as well so if you're
teaching your students uh with the
native pipe and teaching them to sort of
build these tidy verse pipelines they
can learn that workflow and apply it
Beyond working with the Tidy verse as
well should they be using you know a
different package or in a different
courser at some other point in their
life when they're coding in r
um coming back to the Tidy verse uh one
of the updates to the Tidy verse was the
Tidy verse meta package itself so tidy
verse 2.0 was released in um I think
March of this year let's go ahead and
restart our R session one more time and
let's go ahead and load the Tidy verse
package we can see that in the past we
would also have to do something like add
the Liberty load the Liberty Day package
separately but we don't really have to
do that anymore so I'm gonna restart I'm
gonna show you that when I load the Tidy
verse the lubridate package is loaded as
well if you have not used a lubridate
package before or haven't taught the
libertate package before let's go
through its functionality very very
briefly
um perhaps sort of the most important
thing about it as you can tell from the
name is that it allows you to work with
dates and times and these can be pesky
things to work with so let's go ahead
and put today's date this is right now a
numeric uh variable as you can see then
I can use the lubridate packages ymd
function so that starts for E stands for
year month and day and it will convert
that so it will parse that text into a
data object for me this probably seems
pretty straightforward right I mean we
could have probably done this by sort of
string parsing without the lubricate
package as well so let's try something
else let's make it a little bit more
complicated I'm gonna put this as a text
field so I might say 7 19 20 23 and
um we can say that the class of this new
object new variable we created oops
outside today T is a character
this is in the format month day year so
I'm going to use the mdy function
um
and Liberty will convert that for me to
um a date object as well and we can
check that it does that so mdy
today t
and there we go
um this also this is I think like a
little bit more complex but again we
could have easily parsed this string and
said use the Slash the forward slashes
as delimiters so let's make something
even more complex let's create something
like an actual text string
and I will type here something like this
video is being recorded on 19 July 2023
at 1 pm ET
um you can see that the class of this is
um a character so how are we going to
parse the date from here doing so with
sort of uh string parsing would be a
little bit more complicated we would
have to catch that 19 July 2023 there
that might take a bit of um you know
knowing about regular Expressions but
what I can do uh with lubridate is I can
say this is in the order day month and
year and then there's also an hour there
as well
and it will actually go in and try to
parse out the um sort of the date and
time component from that text string now
um the thing is the time zone is
incorrect time zones are additionally uh
pesky so you're you would in this case
let's see
um actually need to add the time zone
itself and now we actually have the
right time there as well and if I look
at the class of this object that we now
created
um that is a posix CP object so
lubridate is pretty helpful for dealing
with you know pesky things like dates
and times and now it comes with the core
tidy verse as well
um next let's go back to when we just
first loaded the Tidy verse package so I
am going to restart my R session and
talk a little bit about conflict
resolution so what do I mean by conflict
resolution what I mean is that when I
load the Tidy verse package you can see
that there is a new
um or updated message it tells me that
there are two functions in the core tidy
verse the filter and lag functions in
the D plier package which masks the
filter and lag function so the functions
with the same name in a package that is
already loaded with base R the stats
package this message has been
um here for some time now but what is
new in tidy verse 2.0 is that it
specifically
um advertises the conflicted package as
well and you can always get back to this
message even if you're not at the
beginning of your R session with the
Tidy versus Flix function which will
sort of print out the end of that
message for you
so let's go ahead and unload that D
plier package so we're going to take out
the D plier package
um and let's try to run this very sort
of common tidy verse pipeline I want to
take the Penguins data frame and filter
it for penguins that are at Elise you've
probably run into this issue before if
you haven't ran into this issue kudos to
you but your students probably have ran
into this What's Happening Here is that
um the message that we get is not that
it can't find the filter function it
can't find the Deep wire filter function
but it is able to find the stats filter
function and it's complaining that you
know it can't find this uh penguin's
object or actually
actually that is probably happening
because we also haven't loaded the
Palmer penguin so let's go back and do
that it is complaining that the object
species is not found so it's sort of not
understanding what you're asking it to
do
the way we would uh base R would resolve
this is if you then load the D plier
package the filter function becomes
available and because it's been loaded
After Base R we're able to
um sort of R will just automatically
choose the version of the function that
was last loaded and things work just
fine
they work just fine until they fail so
if we want to be a little bit more sort
of strict about how we go about things
uh in terms of having multiple packages
loaded with the same function names we
can Leverage The conflicted package
which is not in the court ID verse but
it is a tidy burst packet so I'm going
to go ahead and load that and once I
load conflicted I can no longer get away
with just using the last loaded version
of filter it explicitly tells me look
there are two packages loaded they both
have the filter function in it tell me
which one you want me to use one option
is we can use the sort of the colon
colon notation to say every time I use
filter I can explicitly say I want you
to use the D plier version this is the
sort of thing you might see in sort of
like a package development scenario
perhaps where you want to be very clear
about where other functions from other
packages are coming from but but I think
in a data analysis scenario this gets
pretty busy especially if you're
teaching R especially if you're teaching
you know deeply for the first time
you're probably going to have a bunch of
filter statements and constantly noting
them with deep higher colon colon while
not noting them for all the other
functions that you're teaching I think
can get confusing for the students so
instead you can be uh sort of explicitly
you can explicitly declare which version
of filter you want to use and there you
can say I want to prefer in this R
session going forward the Deep wire
version of filter no more complaints
from the conflicted package and I am
being very sort of explicit in my code
about which version I'm using
um so that was all about the Tidy verse
meta package let's talk a little bit
about uh now the
um sort of improved and expanded
functionality uh with joints so much of
these came with uh updates to D plier
with 1.1.0 onwards I think as of today
we're at 1.1.2 so there's been sort of
additional updates to get uh the rough
edges sorted but generally these updates
are mainly to better align with tools
like SQL and data table so we have here
um a sample data frame so I've created
it Islands data frame where I have noted
the coordinates of sort of the centroid
of these three islands
um and what I'm going to do is I am
going to join the Penguins data frame uh
to this so I'll take the Penguins data
frame and left join it to islands and
this should be a pipeline you're sort of
familiar with
um what we've done in the past was to
use the buy argument and then in here
actually denoted which variable from the
Penguins data frame that's the island
variable should match to which variable
from the islands data frame that's the
name variable
instead what we can do now is we can say
join by so a new function
and I will say where island is equal to
name so with this new notation that is
available to you
um you can actually read this out loud
how we often read out loud logical
statements so double equals is something
we would read out loud as where X is
equal to Y so now I'm able to say take
the Penguins data frame left join it to
the islands data frame by uh where
island is equal to name
um I think that this while the sort of
the previous version the syntax the buy
syntax does not go away I would strongly
recommend updating your teaching
materials to use the join by function
and the thing that is nice about that is
that one this reading out loud is made
so much easier and sort of aligned with
how we read out loud other logical
statements and number two uh when we
work with the um sort of the
older version of this so this we know
worked
um but some other versions worked as
well so I could also do something like
this and this would work as well just
because of how named vectors work in R
but this wouldn't work because it says I
can't find this new name that you're
talking about and we also saw at the
beginning that quoting both of these
work as well
um options are good but sometimes they
can be confusing so by using the join by
notation we no longer need to quote our
variable names which aligns much better
with other functions in the Tidy verse
another update to join functions is
where we have many too many
relationships so I'm going to create a
couple a few more new data frames just
so we have them in our pocket and we can
use them in our examples one of them is
a data frame called three penguins and
this has uh three rows so data on three
penguins and we have one row per sample
ID so imagine that you're a scientist
and you're sort of collecting data on
these penguin samples so this is what my
three Penguins data frame looks like
and then we also have maybe collected by
another scientist let's say data on
weight measurements of these penguins
and if you have ever done things like
collecting uh like date weight data from
um you know animals you probably have
done this thing where you had to measure
at least twice so we have this weight
measurements data where for each of the
sample ID of penguins we have two
measurements as well and finally we have
one more data on flipper length
measurements of these penguins so
similarly we've done two measurements
per um penguin so let's say we have data
from these three separate scientists and
we want to bring them together
I'm going to start by bringing together
the three Penguins data set with uh the
weight measurements data set and there's
just a one-to-many relationship and
things just work fine
um
however when I have many too many
relationships so remember those two
scientists that each take two
measurements from uh each of the three
Penguins if I try to join those weight
measurements and
um
um flipper measurements data frames from
these two scientists now I get a warning
so I get a warning that says that it
detected many too many relationships
between X and Y
um that was unexpected and at the end of
the warning it says if a many-to-many
relationship is expected you can set
relationship equal to many too many
whenever I see you know a warning like
this my first hunch is okay well let's
just try what it tells me to do
um at least it'll shut up the warning
but maybe it will also be the right
thing to do so let's go ahead and add
that so this relationship argument is
new uh with d plier 1.1.0 onwards and in
fact now we have explicitly said yes we
were expecting this many too many
relationship however let's think about
this for a second we started with three
Penguins two measurements per penguin so
six rows of data and we're bringing
together these data from these two signs
but now all of a sudden I have this
explosion of Rose situation I have 12
rows and 12 is not a large number but
imagine if you had hundreds of
measurements from these scientists you
would end up with this explosion of rows
so in this case what we actually should
be doing is instead of denoting a
many-to-many relationship we might
actually think back to our data
structure and say no I want to join by
not just sample ID but by measurement ID
as well
so the join by function can take
multiple variables just like the by
argument of joints can and the
relationship argument of the uh improved
join functions is great for sort of
catching in the tracks of making a
mistake about how you're joining data
sets but the suggestions it gives may
not always be the right suggestion for
your use case so don't just blindly
apply the warnings
um but instead think through your data
structure to see how these um should be
coming together and I think the teaching
tip to take away from here is that when
you're introducing these functions to
the students I would recommend doing
something similar to what I've done here
which is iteratively sort of fall into
the traps that you expect to fall into
or you don't expect to fall into read
the warnings messages or errors out loud
think through them with them together
and then apply uh some sort of solutions
to the problem the explosion of rows uh
problem is something you have probably
come across working particularly with
new Learners who will happily join any
two data frames and sometimes you know
crash their our session or if you're
teaching on a teaching server crash the
whole server so uh sort of walking
through these sorts of examples with
small data sets where they can see how
the rows are expanding or Contracting
back to what we expect them to be I
think is pretty helpful
um another uh new argument is uh
handling unmatched cases with the
improved join function so I'm going to
make one more new data frame this time
my measurements include one more
um penguin uh so I have four penguins in
my data frame and we're gonna say take
the weight measurements from that one
scientist and left join them to these
four penguins
it's fine it R will happily join them
for you but poof that fourth penguin is
gone
um maybe you never wanted the fourth
penguin and maybe this is exactly what
you wanted but
um it is likely the case that this was a
much larger data set and some of these
unmatched cases sort of silently
disappeared
um and you never caught them
so one option is to say well I
definitely don't care any of the
Penguins whose weights I don't have so
I'm going to explicitly use an inner
join to solve this problem not a left
join so saying that I only want the
penguins that are common between these
two another option is to actually use
the
um unmatched argument and say when I do
this join anything that's unmatched
explicitly drop that so again the
results we're getting from these is
exactly the same and in fact you can
also do nothing you can do exactly what
you did at the beginning but do it at
your own risk so the difference between
using the unmatched argument
um or not is basically saying that I'm
making it very explicit when I come back
to this code I want to remember that I
explicitly did not care about the other
Penguins whose weights we did not have
another argument you can another value
you can use for the unmatched argument
is actually error so this might be a
good starting place where it says
if there's any unmatched cases just
error out I will stop at that point and
read through the error and then decide
what I want to do so the error tells me
that each row of Y Must Be matched with
X and in this case Row 4 of Y was not
matched
and now it's basically telling you
decide what you want to do with it and
you might go back to saying fine drop
that one
so the error uh value for unmatched is a
great starting Place particularly for
interactive data analysis and then you
want to explicitly choose uh one of the
values and sort of uh go with that
all right so we've talked about joins in
New D plier let's talk about one other
feature of the most recent deep fire
package which is per operation grouping
so I'm going to start with a very
typical tidy verse pipeline here I want
to plot the mean body weights of
penguins by species and sex so I'm going
to start with the Penguins data set just
for ease I'm going to drop any of the
Penguins for which we don't have body
mass or sex information
and then I am going to group them by
species and sex so I can see that this
is now a group data frame and then I'm
going to summarize to calculate
um uh the mean body weights uh per
species and sex of these penguins and
then let's go ahead and actually make a
plot of this
now you can see that when I make this
plot or even earlier when I just did my
summary there was a message that got
printed out it says summarize has
grouped output by species you can
override this using the dot dot groups
argument so this message
um which can sort of Catch You by
surprise particularly if you're doing
something like creating a plot where you
know summarize is not even the last
statement in your uh data pipeline is
basically saying that you had grouped
the data by two variables when we ran
summarize we sort of peeled off that
last grouping variable but the data are
still grouped by species and turns out
for making this plot it doesn't make any
difference so you can happily sort of
ignore that message but what generally
tends to happen is that if we don't
address this issue that the data frame
is still grouped this can result in
frustrating situations particularly for
new learners but trust me even for
experienced users because the data
underlying this is now remain grouping
and sometimes this can have Downstream
effects it didn't have it on the GG plot
but let's look at a couple examples
so here for example I am grouping the
data by species and sex again I am going
to find the mean body weights again and
then I want the top row of that output
but if I actually drop my groups then
the top row of that output is just one
row so
um when we have grouping that persists
through the pipeline certain functions
will then output slightly different
results and if you were expecting one
and you get the other or vice versa it
can be pretty confusing to try to catch
where did this happen another example I
like to give with this is using the
wonderful GT package for making tables
here I have uh data that is still
grouped after uh running the summarize
function so the GT package will nicely
group my output and uh display this
output for me as such however when I
actually explicitly drop my groups that
grouping structure goes away so GT
doesn't apply that sort of nice grouping
which one you want the idea is you
probably want to be explicit about that
so one of the options that we saw is
that every time you run summarize you
can decide what you want to do with your
groups you can decide to group them
sorry drop them which means the
remaining data frame is not grouped or
you can decide that you want to uh
assign another value to this like keep
or keep last for example
alternatively with new d-plier you have
a new Option per operation grouping so
you can see that in this new pipeline I
do not have a group by statement anymore
I start with my data frame I did the
dropping the Nas and then I said
summarize to calculate the mean body
masses for me
but do that by species so this new DOT
by argument allows me to um
do the grouping in the operation where I
am doing the summarization and the
resulting data frame is no longer
grouped and I can actually do this by
species and sex like we were doing
before and again the resulting data
frame is not grouped I didn't have to
explicitly say once you're done with it
drop the groups which I think is a
slightly less sort of straightforward or
intuitive way of going about things but
here we're just explicitly saying when
you're summarizing Group by these two
variables and when you're done don't
leave the data frame grouped anymore
so my recommendation would be I think to
consider
um teaching the dot by
um version of this like per operation
grouping particularly if you find that
your learners tend to uh struggle with
persistent grouping in deep plier
pipelines that being said
um the new version of our for data
science which very recently came out
right here
um does mention the dot by argument for
uh per operation grouping but it doesn't
dwell on it too much so a majority of
the presentation still uses Group by so
you can decide based on how strictly you
want to stick to the text or not if you
are using that text for your teaching
all right one more bit on D plier
um my most favorite function case when
for some reason I really like that
function
um so now it has gotten some updates as
well some quality of life improvements
um let's start with this I'm going to
calculate some quantiles for the
Penguins data set so I have the 25th uh
percentile and the 75th percentile of my
data and using these I want to
categorize my Penguins as small medium
or large so if a penguin is less than 35
50 grams I'm going to label them small
if they're between these two I'm going
to label them medium and if they're
greater than 47.50 I'm going to label
them large
um and if they were Nas I want to leave
them as an A's so here uh what we're
seeing is this would be a typical sort
of case when
um uh pipeline where the last
row or the last call says
if it's not any of these so if they'll
then call it true and for those rows
label things large
um let's also do something that will
allow us to more easily see what's going
on in this pipeline uh whenever I have a
data frame that's sort of wide with lots
of columns and the columns that I'm
operating with I can't see when I run my
pipeline I like moving them up so I
probably will want to move up here
um the body mass
and the new variable that I created the
BM cat variable so let's relocate those
to move them up so that I can sort of
spot check that my assignment is working
well in fact we might temporarily pipe
this to the view function just to make
sure that we have some larges as well so
indeed in our data frame we do have some
larges as well I have personally always
found explaining why we call this true a
little challenging when teaching case
when
um because it's not you know you're not
necessarily reading out all the
conditions and even if you do I want to
say something like if all else fails so
case one has gained a new argument
called dot default that basically says
if it's not any of those make it large
so now we can achieve the same
um outcome without sort of using the
true as a catch-all for anything that
didn't match
and finally with G plier I want to
highlight what I think is a very
exciting uh development with ifels
k-swan and friends so let's say that I
have my data frame
um you know something like this and I
want to create a new variable that
actually shows the unit so the grams
next to the values as well so let's say
I want to have something like this
for each of the
body masses I also want to have a
character value that brings together the
value and the units
um it used to be that you had to type n
a character here because all the other
values in that column were characters so
now you have to introduce to do this
very simple task of creating a character
string from a numeric the notion that
there are different sorts of Nas in R
and I think that's a pretty like high
level thing to be mentioning so now you
can actually get away with calling this
n a and don't have to worry about any
character or other ni variants where I
think they don't necessarily belong as
early in an introductory or R curriculum
as what we have here
um next let's take let's leave deep wire
aside and take a bit of a detour and
um talk about
um tidier and specifically separating
columns so I have a new data frame here
data on penguins with text string
description so maybe you have a
different scientist who instead of
putting things in a spreadsheet have has
put them in a Word document or something
and you have these um
three specimens and some descriptions
about them and what you might want to do
is take these descriptions and turn them
into a data frame or a spreadsheet
version
um the separate function existed
previously in
um tidier but it has sort of evolved to
allow for different ways of separating
so one option is to separate and we want
to separate wider because we want to put
these pieces of information in columns
that go next to each other as opposed to
longer into additional rows we want to
separate wider this description column
and we want the delimiter to be the
comma so I want something like this
um for one of my variables and something
like this for my other variable and I'm
going to create call those new variables
species and Island
this gives me something uh perhaps a bit
more useful than these descriptions but
there's a lot of repeated information
so if you are into that sort of thing of
writing regular Expressions you can
actually take things one step further
with a new function called separate
wider regex where you can actually give
a regular expression patterns to it and
in one go result in something like a
species column and an island column
without the repeated information if you
are teaching regular Expressions I would
say this is the way to go if you're not
teaching regular expressions in your
class or before you teach regular
Expressions you could do something like
this and then use some functions from
the string r package like Str remove to
get rid of the Redundant species and
Island tap tags here
another exciting development here though
is something about
um
what happens when things don't work out
as expected so if you look at the
documentation for these new separate
functions you will see some new um
arguments as well
uh specifically to few or too many so
what to do if there are too few
components should they be aligned at the
start aligned at the end or should just
give you an error so that you can look
into it or if there are too many of them
uh what to do should they be dropped or
should they be merged with the last one
and the debug option here basically will
print out something it's probably not
something you want in your final code
but it's very helpful for interactive
use where you can take a look to see
what to do and then make a decision in
terms of whether a line start align or
align end makes more sense
um we've talked about a lot of new
exciting updates so I'd like to wrap
this up by talking about something maybe
a little bit more light-hearted so one
minor update to ggplot2 this is not the
only update I think that has happened to
ggplot2 but one that continues to catch
me in my tracks is
um a new argument for
um changing how your lines look so for
line GM so if I do something like this
where I am plotting flipper length
versus body mass of penguins and I want
an overlay a smooth curve over it but I
want that line to be a bit thicker
um the you will get a warning that says
please use LINE width instead of size I
do agree that line width is indeed the
uh seems to be more appropriate here uh
in terms of what to call that and I've
in the past struggled with sort of
articulating why it was called size that
being said
um I will say that
the best teaching tip I can give you is
just check the output of your old
teaching materials thoroughly do not
make a fool of yourself when you're
teaching to constantly see this warning
pop up at an unexpected time
so I've tried to go through much of the
code that is in the accompanying blog
post and sort of interactively explain
some of these updates I should mention
and emphasize that much of what I've
talked through are things that you can
now do optionally and in places where I
feel like that is an improvement in the
context of teaching I try to highlight
those you could also just not do any of
these things chances are none of your
code is going to fail per se unless
there was something happening that was
an error to begin with that was sort of
slipping through but I think that these
updates are nice to sort of think about
as we approach the new Academic Year and
as you might be thinking about
what to change or what to update in your
teaching materials
um and remember that the tidyverse blog
is a great place to catch up with all
tidy verse updates uh whether teaching
related or not there's been a lot of
other updates to the packages that if
you sort of dig through this year's post
that you will see to string guard to
tidier to four cats a new API for the
Arvest package and also if you also tend
to teach SQL along with your data
science content
um shorter and more readable and in some
cases faster SQL queries in DB choir and
I'll wrap up by saying that the new
version of our for data science is out
and much of the updates that I've talked
about here were sort of done in order to
catch up with what we wanted to Showcase
in the book so you can expect the
development to slow down a little bit as
you sort of phase in these new changes
into your teaching materials thank you
very much for listening
[Music]
foreign